DOESN'T MEAN WE HAVEN'T BECOME
MORE LIKE RUSSIA.
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY FOR THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA IS
JOINING US NOW.
JOE, I WANT TO STATE AT THE
OUTSET, HE LIED!
SAY NEWS ANCHORS.
HE LIED.
HE DESERVES WHATEVER IS COMING
TO HIM.
ASSESS THAT CLAIM.
IF YOU WOULD.
>> HE DID NOT LIE.
THE F.B.I. KNEW IT.
THIS IS A CONTEXTUAL CRIME
CREATED BY THE F.B.I. AND
SALLY YATES THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
REMEMBER AFTER THE ELECTION,
HILLARY CLINTON NEEDED A
REASON WHY SHE LOST.
ENTER RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
PART OF THAT WAS TO FIND
SOMEBODY IN THE ADMINISTRATION
TO FRAME TALKING TO THE
RUSSIANS.
THEY FOUND GENERAL FLYNN.
IN FACT, ALL OF GENERAL
FLYNN'S CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR AND
EVERYBODY ELSE WERE LEGAL.
SO WHY DID THE F.B.I. APPROACH
HIM?
THEY KNEW WHAT HE SAID.
THEY KNEW IT WAS LEGAL.
THE ANSWER IS THEY WANTED TO
FRAME HIM.
THEY SUCCEEDED.
HE DID NOT TELL THEM FALSE
INFORMATION.
SOME OF IT MAY HAVE BEEN CAUSE
OR NUANCE, HE DID NOT LIE.
INDEED THE AGENT WHO ACTUAL
302s ARE AVAILABLE SAID HE
DIDN'T LIE.
AND IT'S INTERESTING THAT
MUELLER DID NOT TURN OVER THE
ORIGINAL 302s TO JUDGE
SULLIVAN TODAY.
HE TURNED OVER AN INTERVIEW OF
AGENT STROZK WHICH WAS DONE
MONTHS LATER BY MUELLER'S
PEOPLE.
THE ANSWER IS MICHAEL FLYNN
WAS FRAMED TO GET DONALD
TRUMP.
SALLY YATES, JAMES COMEY,
PETER STROZK, ANDREW McCABE
ALL PLANNED IT.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING PLAY OUT
IN AN AMERICAN COURTROOM IS
ONE OF THE MOST DISGRACEFUL
EVENTS IN AMERICAN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE.
AND EVERYBODY ON MUELLER'S
TEAM SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES AND NONE OF THEM
SHOULD EVER BE ALLOWED TO GO
BACK IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: ANY ATTORNEY WHO
ADVISED MICHAEL FLYNN TO PLEAD
GUILTY RATHER THAN GOING
PUBLIC WITH THE FRAMEUP
HAPPENING TO HIM SHOULD BE
DISBARRED, I THINK.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
REACTION TO IT?
A LOT OF PEOPLE WATCHING, EVEN
ON THIS CHANNEL PRETTY WELL
INFORMED NEWS CONSUMERS ARE
SURPRISED TO LEARN THAT THE
CRIME HERE, THE ONLY CRIME
HERE ARISES FROM THE
LAWYERLESS INTERVIEW IN WHITE
HOUSE.
FLYNN WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH
COLLUDING WITH ANYBODY.
INCLUDING THE TURKS.
YOU HEARD THAT HE WAS WORKING
WITH ERDOGAN.
HE WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH
THAT.
HE HAS BEEN DESTROYED AS A
MAN.
THE FAMILY IS CRUSHED AND
BANKRUPTCY AND HAD TO SELL THE
HOUSE ON THE BASIS OF ONE
CRIME.
WHY DIDN'T ANYBODY ON ANY
OTHER NETWORK SAY COULDN'T IT
BE SLIGHTLY DISPROPORTIONATE?
>> WELL, THE PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER NETWORK WANTED ONE
THING.
THEY WANTED TO FIND A WAY TO
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE
HE WASN'T SUPPOSED TO BE
ELECTED.
BUT HE BEAT THEM.
ONCE THEY WERE BEATEN THEY GOT
ANGRY AND THEN THEY GOT
VINDICTIVE.
THEN THEY GOT VINDICTIVE USING
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
WEAPONIZING IT.
JOHN BRENNAN AT THE C.I.A. AND
JAMES CLAPPER FOLLOWED THROUGH
ON THE PROMISE THREAT TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO GET THE
PEOPLE THEY DIDN'T WANT
ELECTED TO MAKE UP FOR THE
FACT THAT SHE, HILLARY
CLINTON, HAD LOST.
THIS HAS BECOME ONE OF THE
GREATEST SCANDALS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY AND THE
MEDIA IS IGNORING IT.
IT'S TRULY IMPORTANT THAT WHAT
YOU ARE DOING BY FOCUSING ON
THE STORIES CONTINUE TO BE
DONE UNTIL THERE IS A NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THERE CAN
BE A GRAND JURY TO FIND OUT
WHO WAS IT THAT LEAKED
CONVERSATION OF MICHAEL FLYNN
WITH THE RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR?
THAT WAS A CRIME.
THE LEAK TO DAVID IGNACIOS OF
THE "WASHINGTON POST" TO
EXPOSE MICHAEL FLYNN'S
CONVERSATION WITH THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR WAS A CRIME.
THE QUESTION TONIGHT IS WHY
ISN'T THAT CRIME BEING
INVESTIGATED?
>> Tucker: BECAUSE EVERYONE
IN WASHINGTON IS DEEPLY
INVESTED IN THE FAILED FOREIGN
POLICY AND ANYBODY WHO
SUGGESTS CHANGING THE FOREIGN
POLICY THEY ARE DEEPLY